hey everyone welcome back to gamespot
it's a busy gdc week here and we have
plenty of guests coming through our
offices in san francisco california i'm
excited for this live stream in
particular i'm here with ralph cole
antonio creative director on prey
hi and ricardo barrett lead designer
hello both here from arcane studios from
austin texas i believe that's right and
uh we're gonna be playing some prey uh
we're gonna jump into a save about 15
minutes after the beginning yeah uh you
know a while back we let a bunch of
people play the first hour of the game
and uh i think a lot of people put
videos of it up
so we thought that we would start a
little bit past the point that everybody
is talking about that's sort of like a
spoiler so um so if you want if you want
to watch the beat the first 15 minutes
and see the spoiler then uh go watch one
of those videos but we're going to jump
in 15 minutes uh after that point sort
of like dive right into the gameplay
cool so yeah everybody if you're joining
on youtube or twitch or gamespot welcome
and uh we're excited to play this let's
uh jump right in i guess all right
load up my save
let's see
which one is it it's this guy there we
go
so this is like
right after breaking out uh so we don't
really have any weapons or powers or
anything yet so we're gonna sort of get
introduced to all that stuff
cool
so all you have is a wrench at first
that's right
very classic starting weapon
so we're sort of breaking out of an
experiment that we've been trapped in
for a little while now
so you in on the space station right now
or is that something we should know or
no
i actually don't know that okay yeah you
escaped some place
and these are the so this is a mimic
which is a
one of our monsters part of our ecology
in our aliens race and uh
here we should show how they multiply
because the mimics are able to transform
into
objects in the environment and hide from
you
so it could be anything in this room it
could be anything so but if you look
like there are two shoes over here
it's very suspicious nobody has three
shoes that's not right
so based on based on the playthroughs
you know sometimes it's something else
like it could be also the towels or
whatever
because it's all systemic they
just turn into anything that is close to
them cool
we have a lot of cool little rpg
features too which you get exposed to
the more and more you play the game but
you'll notice the the creatures have
these uh
organs that you can harvest and then
there are some other uh body parts that
you can't take until you have the the
right skill
and those you can then use to like
harvest or to create like cool uh items
later on okay cool
correct me if i'm wrong but as opposed
to uh dishonored and dishonored two
arcane's other projects
prey is like an open open structure
right yeah uh yeah it's it's actually uh
it's pretty much an open world it's just
that the
environment that
that we chose is is not a forest or a
city so it's uh it's actually a space
station but you can it's all contiguous
you can go anywhere and or you can also
go all around it uh when you fly in zero
g around it cool
yeah so here's our uh you know this is
the beginning of the game so we're sort
of introducing the player to our game
mechanics and so right here is like hey
just because you ran into a locked door
in this game it doesn't mean you have to
find the key you can find the key but
there are other ways around like for
instance this room has a little crawl
crawl shaft that we could go through so
uh
i think i want to do that this time
i'm getting super freaked out
this is super fun because uh every time
we play this it's different because the
mimic's not
scripted to be any particular thing um
they just if you put a mimic if a level
designer puts a mimic in a room they
just they they can look at all the
physics objects in the room and and
decide real time what they want to be
so it's surprising even for us cool
in terms of like
i don't know like story-wise the mimics
no they're pretty weak so that's their
defense mechanism yeah they all have a
purpose like in the ecology of uh um
in the in the game and so the mimics
actually the scouts they are the ones
who hide collect energy and then
multiply and keep on scouting
but i'm reading the comments it's so
distracting
someone says that it's on mega drive
actually
[Music]
yeah for those just uh just joining we
are playing on pc
for those curious the mega drive version
will be out soon
so the special edition
i think my kids might be watching hi
sword and sofia now look away because
none of this content is appropriate for
children
hopefully we age-gated it that's right
all right so that's the that's the glue
gun it's uh
one of the
weapons that actually people have
noticed because it's you know it's
different than most weapons in other
games
um
and it's initially it's uh you use it on
aliens to contain you to when they
escape from containment it's a way to
control them so that they
can be uh
uh
paralyzed in a way okay but people use
them for matter for other ways so we'll
see that in a minute okay
so one may make is okay but when you
have like this like there were four five
or six minutes then it starts to get
harder
yeah busted it's like a charged up
attack you just did yeah yes
and sorry go ahead i was gonna say
probably what you're gonna say it's a
charge attack and because they were
still in their mimic form
then
oh that was funny uh he turned into a
coffee cup that was awesome it was
rolling yeah oh so they do lose some
like uh hp when they're in their
fake form it's more like it counts as a
surprise attack okay
because we also have the concept of
surprise attacks okay if they don't see
you when you attack them then they
should take some damage okay
yeah one of the concepts behind the
combat here like the mimics are
they're they're scary because they can
hide and ambush you but they're not
super strong they're pretty easy to
knock out once you stop them
but a bunch of the other aliens
are much stronger so one of the like
approaches to combat and pray is like
try to disable your opponents first and
so the glue gun is one way to disable
opponents there are other ways that
we'll show in a little bit but
going typically just like hey i'm just
going to go toe-to-toe with this
alien that's usually that's not a good
strategy in this game okay
especially if there's like 12 of them
just like that yeah exactly
um
all right so i think we're i think we're
safe right now yep no we're not sorry
i just whipped that guy
i love we've seen in previous previews
we've done at gamespot i love when you
open a door and the mimics notice you
and then kind of
warp really quick as if you didn't see
that scatter yeah
yeah because that's that's that's what's
cool with simulation right is that
they're just doing their thing and some
and most of the time it works out to
their benefit where they can actually
hide for real but sometimes you actually
can see them hiding yeah it feels cool
someone is asking about endings the
answer is no we have a lot of different
endings for the game
do you want to talk about neuromods yeah
uh so
this is very distracting
i know it's hard not to just yes i'm not
to just read all these questions uh so
the neural mods uh in our game the
we have those things called linear mods
and people use them to uh acquire
abilities new abilities right and it's
actually
you find out as you play the game that
it's actually linked to the uh the
purpose of this station as well as space
stations okay and what this company is
actually developing they're developing
those things to learn abilities
uh and so it also justifies of course an
rpg tree
and here we see the three main
archetypes that the player can evolve to
and we map those archetypes to
uh
the the population that would be on one
of the stations so the you know
scientists engineers and security
officers right
and you can mix and match between them
okay yeah you can mention mac so
what should we do this time should we do
combat focus yeah let's do combat would
be cool and and one thing that is
interesting of course like you see three
uh branches here for three trees but uh
but then later on you can also acquire
uh abilities from the aliens themselves
and we're not gonna show this in this
demo but it's
basically three new trees yeah yeah that
opens
the mimic ability comes in with yeah and
then because you see them turning into
things you can you can also learn that
so anything you see an alien do you can
actually actually learn it and of course
uh in the future
the only way to upgrade your mind is to
stab needles
directly into your eyes yeah that's the
truth that's the only way it can work
geez
all right
i guess it's a trade-off
for having alien superpowers yeah it's
totally worth it
somebody ask if you can still break your
legs the answer is no
all right so um
there's the typical path that you can
take in the game but like we were saying
the glue gun has more than one use so
you saw us freeze enemies with it um
show off another use
if i'd taken the repair skill
i could probably fix this elevator shaft
right here this gravity lift
uh but instead i'm gonna use the glue
gun what did you think
i took combat focus come on yeah if i
had repair and i found enough spare
parts i could i could fix this crap i
was gonna say otherwise you could hack
the
go into the booth too oh yeah that's
true if i'd taken hacking i could have
uh hacked my way into this security
booth and maybe gotten gotten some
goodies out of there but i don't have
hacking could you find the code to that
pass lock some of them can so some of
them are hackable and you can find the
code and some of them the keypad's just
like shorted out like this one is okay
so the only way to get in is to hack
hack your way past it do you have a zero
four five one code somewhere in there
yes
so i'm gonna like glue climb my way up
here you're just gonna try anyway i'm
gonna try
i'm gonna hope i don't uh break fall and
break or die rather
oh
no wait i made it kind of
let's try that again
so there's like a clamber mechanic yeah
i think you should probably do on the
angle first
yeah see that's the
let's do this we're being way too brave
i know
but that's the point is that those those
kind of mechanics you can experience
experiment with them and people will
find ways to
break the game in good ways you know
yeah by by doing things that did not
because that's so super not legit and
yeah
it's just trying here
yeah i remember like even like after
dishonored 2 release i remember uh
harvey smith at arcane was saying that
you know you see stuff the players are
doing things that the developers didn't
even you know take into consideration i
made it a good example this was kind of
a lot of work but it worked out
so i'm in an area where
later if i come back and i have higher
hacking skill or
some other abilities then there's some
offices up here and some laboratories
that i could access that i i just don't
have the means to access right now okay
but because i climbed up here i i'm
actually gonna
find a weapon that uh if i hadn't been
able to climb up here i would find it
much later in the game but players who
do this will find it early
this is a cool weapon called the
disrupter stun gun and it's basically
another way to disable enemies
works really well against uh robotic
types too
cool
what's your overarching
goal right now
uh for this protagonist so
the
[Music]
you know you start the game and you are
mostly
surprised and trying to escape a place
that is uh danvers and that's that's
pretty much the main motive at first
okay it's like
it's like well okay i gotta survive
basically so i gotta find and all you
have is that there's a mysterious
uh contact that talks to you and uh and
through your um
a device called the transcribe which is
some sort of a comment
and uh and they tell you to go and meet
them
in your office and you're like what i
have an office so that's that's how the
game starts okay and uh so you don't
quite know exactly what you're doing
here so little by little you're going to
find out why you're here and
what was the purpose of that but also
your ultimate goal at this very moment
is to escape
the space station
someone is asking if it's using the cry
engine the answer is yes
and uh praise for game boy of course
no it's not it's kind of
it's coming out on calculators
everywhere
um yeah so i just picked up the shotgun
also but ammo is a little is scarce in
the game and uh we put the ammo here
just for the purposes of the demo and
the in the actual shipping game
you'll have to work a little harder to
find the shotgun okay
so this is where you learned that like
uh you're not you're not on earth at all
you're already in a space station
i mean uh both dishonored and this from
the looks of it kind of harken back to
you know like the looking glass origin
days you know with uh like the original
thief with deus ex and ion storm with
you know system shock and it's kind of
at the time those games were pretty
ahead of their time right people weren't
used to those first-person sims it seems
like big thing arcane is pushing it's
bringing those back right yeah and you
know i think uh most artists they will
you know you you you see how
art always comes back to 20 years
earlier you know like
black keys on the sound like uh yeah you
know and it's because probably what they
were listening when the kids and uh it's
the same for for us right we were
touched by games from looking glass i
mean i was 16 when i was playing
ultimate underworld yeah uh it branded
me
to life yeah so now if you find some of
those same values some of the same
things that touched us hopefully
somebody who will be playing prey at
some point and we'll
20 years from now we'll be doing some
yeah yeah so it's pro inspired game
like it's like a futuristic art deco oh
what was that
there is a phantom in this museum oh
crap
all right so that's another type of
alien uh this one
can shoot it shifts around
um
it also hides that's
sometimes it just vanishes you don't
know what happened and it goes hide
somewhere
um
so would this gun stun a human for
longer or
yeah okay
oh
that's the worst feeling
oh and i'm out of bullets now
yeah it's a lot about a lot of this game
is to about surviving
scavenging anything you can recycling
stuff creating new a new ammo for
example if you're the guy who wants to
shoot a lot okay
industry i just found an upgrade kit
yeah so this time we're playing kind of
like the shooter playthrough yeah that's
what you say yeah so did you show the
the focus combat focus yet
no i forgot i had it i'm gonna okay i'll
use it in the next fight is that the
upgrade you got from the tree yes
so great from the looks of it the
inventory management is kind of like a
residual four mini
that have good progression yeah yeah
cool
okay
tetris or if you want to go further back
yeah i'm so sorry come on now that makes
way more sense in the context of this
yeah
i feel like every time i'm trying to
let's use comments
so this combat focus it basically slows
everything down
except you it slows you down a little it
slows them down more than it slows yeah
so
yeah so it's it's a classic think fast
kind of thing but uh but it's very
useful in combat and it's a good it's a
good skill to to buy if
if you want to uh if you want to take
the path of the more shooter type of
gamer
you know what i've never i've never seen
that key there yeah
well something just blew up right there
um
so we we have a mission uh we just broke
out of this experiment and apparently
somebody left a video for us to watch in
our office so one of the things you
learn is like
i'm not just this test subject i i also
apparently i worked here on the space
station and i've been here for years and
i just can't remember any of it sure and
so you're headed to we're headed to our
office
to watch a video but the lobby level
that we're in is like this huge uh hub
and so you could you could go directly
to your office and keep the story moving
forward but you could spend hours in
here just like
you know delving into side offices
finding out about some of the former
crew members finding like crafting
supplies and whatnot yeah i'm going to
go uh you know i'm going to go into the
trauma center this time before
i go
to my office
fake oh fake out
because i just found that key yeah
that's the one i was saying
before
i would expect to find a bunch of like
medical supplies and stuff in here
there's a phantom in there i don't want
to go that way
so someone is asking if we're playing on
xbox we're actually playing on pc right
now
yeah for those just joining this is uh
we're playing prey from arcane studios
uh i'm here with ralph calantonia
creative director and ricardo barrett
lead designer
we're playing on pc we're about 25 20
minutes into the game at this point i
froze that guy around the fire so like
most of his health is already gone
because
he's walking through those flames but
this is what the glue gun lets you do it
lets you slow slow them down and
eventually you get this tool called the
psychoscope which lets you scan them and
take their abilities from them cool
another thing you can do with the glue
gun is plug up fire leaks which i
shouldn't have plugged that one up
because it would have killed him just
helped him out yeah there he goes he
died
yeah so you mentioned that like uh the
alien powers kind of functioning within
like an ecology in this game you know
with dishonored it's like wailing right
and that and whale oil powers a lot of
stuff what's it like creating an
entirely new universe here as opposed to
the one you've been working with uh
since 2012 with dishonored
uh well we love doing that and it's
one of the most fun
and it takes forever as well it's long
it's a long process you don't you know
you come in the morning with a with a
world already created
it's like a canvas that gets slowly
painted and it's it's really fun it's
the the the way we do it in our case is
that we um
diagnosis um we come up with uh with the
narrative of how the why and how the
world became what it is right now and so
once you have this these filters this
then every all of your art assets all of
your design all of your
uh future stories fall into
through those those pillars those those
those narrative that you create
uh and so that's why
bring something that is cohesive and
everything comes together as opposed to
just putting random elements together
right
that's that's why you have some
form of unity
yeah it makes it a more uh you know
believable world right yeah despite the
fact that it's a lot of supernaturalish
stuff happening extraterrestrial cool
yeah
this guy's uh i found this person here
who's
quarantined in the trauma center
eventually so when you break out and you
get into the space station um
the disaster just happened it's not like
you're coming months afterwards okay
so people
uh most of the people
most of the people on the space station
are dead but you will occasionally run
into survivors and sometimes you run
into people who have been uh possessed
by an alien called a telepath
and they know that they're possessed but
they can't control themselves and so you
have to decide what to do with them you
know i mean because they're threatening
you but on the other hand they're like
you know get away ron i can't i can't
stop myself you know so you have to
there's a little bit of a moral element
there of like do i do i take these
people out or i try to avoid them okay
this is a little we also have a couple
of more like ambient creatures too like
these medical operators that uh
if you're wounded you can you can summon
them to heal you
let's see if i can get over to this area
look at the little grenade you had now
has an emp grenade amp
whoa
almost busted there a lot of verticality
this yep space station too yes
absolutely
so if you were to die and reload like a
checkpoint five minutes ago would that
mimic
maybe be there maybe not yeah okay maybe
maybe not yeah yeah some of them are uh
replaced most of the very beginning of
the game because we want to you know the
player to get familiar with yeah
and there are some effects sometimes
that we want to achieve but most of them
are not most of them could be anything
see
see something yeah i know there's some
mimics in here yeah because a bunch of
furniture was basically wiggled
so i can't use this
do i have any bullets left nope
you have to just smash them
so here of course we could
i mean maybe i'm going to repeat what
recorder is saying that you know
sometimes distracted with this screen
over there
um
we could go to directly to the goal but
but were we're trying to show how much
extra content there is
beyond the main goal there's always like
the main
objective but but uh i don't know were
you part of the people who played uh
no no
yeah
i've watched it though yeah
do you want to talk about uh recyclers
oh crap let me kill this guy yeah so
uh as mentioned earlier a lot of the
game is about survival and you know you
you are
sometimes stopping for resource and whip
and bullets for example so
you can actually gather uh things that
are useless and put them in the recycler
like this so we're going to show that
and obtain some recycling elements with
them
and so then later on there's another
machine somewhere that we'll show
probably just after which is called the
fabricator if you have the right
fabrication plans you can pretty much
create any item of the game and so it's
another layer of
how you as a player can choose how you
want to play okay
so there's a bunch of trash items you
know
baseball gloves
mushrooms or lemon peels
and then some things that i don't care
about like the oxygen tanks
that i'm going to recycle
and uh you know we for us it was
important to do all the recycling and
the fabricating to make it in world like
this so it feels all integrated and very
physical as opposed to like some
abstracts
okay
kind of feeds it feeds into the idea
like you were saying earlier having a
ecology for this game that makes sense
yeah yeah
so this door is broken but like later in
the game if i had the mimic power i
could turn into something small and
tumble under there so i'm gonna have to
go back the way i came
yeah i saw i think it was our gameplay
when i saw someone like turn into
something pretty small but then used
some sort of kinetic burst to launch
themselves oh yeah there was an older
video we did for quick con
should i go fight these are going to the
i.t area
sure i'll have to take hacking because
yeah
okay so i'm going to take the hacking
skills so i can get into this it area
yeah so the the thing you're referring
to was um
it was an example of how systems can
combine in interesting ways and so
the player back then was demonstrating
how to reach a
high area that he could not there was no
stairs or anything for it but so it
turned into this rolling you i think it
was a recycled charge
and then uh com as it was a recyclable
charge like this little grenade thing he
choses to use the um
his blast power
uh and he propelled himself a board okay
which was uh
which was interesting and we know we
would never ask players to do that but
uh some of them will do it yeah yeah
so this is a hacking there's a little
hacking minigame you can play
hopefully i'll get it the first time but
i probably i'll probably fail
or not oh what's up
i got it what happens if you hit those
red ones uh you you get shocked and it
slows you down uh okay
somebody was asking what the phantoms
are saying
yeah so the phantom actually used to be
human
uh that's what you kind of figure out as
you play uh they are turned into
phantoms by another creature called the
the weaver okay
uh and so they still have some memories
and some some of their some of the
expressions are still using the the
human argument voice even though it's
processed of course okay you can tell
they're coming because they have this
like electromagnetic field that just
like blows out the lights around them oh
cool yeah that's to the dramatic effect
yeah there he is
oh i don't have any shotgun shells left
this is not going to be easy
oh you can also um
you can bash this thing and be lucky
yes
so how many uh like abilities
it almost killed me but it didn't i
think i got one of them with it
oh man
i'm just going to hide in her desk and
cry
so of course if you hide they
yeah they will look for you and um
there's a there's a stealth system which
is not as
encouraged as it is in dishonored but uh
the dishonored is way more stealth
focused but there is there is some
stealth system so that at least it's
part of the simulation
catches
so later on when you do have the ability
to do the mimic uh power
if you set phantom's looking at you if
you turn into a mug right in front of
him he's going to know it's you right
yeah you're going to do it before you're
in there
yeah so i found a chipset uh do you want
to talk about the chips yeah chipsets
are a little bit of the equivalent of
bone charms in dishonored so um
they're another layer of customization
as if we did not have any uh enough you
know
and so
you you see the suit chipset and
actually there's also the scope chipsets
you can see right next to them this is
another thing we'll see maybe in a
future demo
uh and those really what they are is
like little improvement uh that can pile
between each other with each other and
so and there are more cheap sets in a
game that there is in in a playthrough
so every time you play you won't have
exactly the same ones yeah and right now
there's only two that can be activated
at the same time but of course you can
improve your suit so that now you can
have three four five
yeah if you take if you if you uh invest
in the engineer abilities there's
uh
neural mods you can do that uh give you
more inventory space and also allow you
to add more chipsets
yeah someone asked if you can beat the
game without being spotted
so no you can't
again there are there are some moments
where we will have to talk to people
see as opposed to dishonored which you
know like it could encourage a very
combat-oriented play-through for the
first one or maybe as you know emily and
then a stealth play through his corvo or
vice versa uh is that kind of how prey
is going to unfold like one way or the
other or mix and match or it's probably
going to be a little bit less
predictable
uh so what do you mean exactly i mean
like feel like uh you know dishonored a
lot of times people would pick i'm going
to go stealthy this play through combat
is that kind of like how this might
unfold or just a little less predictable
right well uh there are probably more
this is more like a blend of archetypes
so you can really uh overall there's way
more trees and there are more uh ways to
customize your your character okay
and your play style i think i had a
freeze up here
well
oh man
we'll reset that quick
yeah
this is an early beta build still so we
have occasionally
just reply your questions yeah cool yeah
if you have questions for uh
ricardo here in the chat uh send them
our way if you're just joining us we're
playing prey right now we've just got a
few technical issues in the studio but
uh have it back up and running and uh
yeah so uh pray will be on
pc xbox one ps4 on may 5th yep
and we're here with uh what's the what's
the release date for expertise too
that's a secret
somebody asked if we had a weapon
degradation
um that's an interesting same question
and someone also asked about the
breaking legs thing and yeah we
you know it's not not sure yet but we so
it's not in the game because uh it was
uh too hardcore too complicated for most
gamers but we uh
we've been thinking and i don't know we
we're not it's not guaranteed we've been
thinking of maybe doing a release later
where there's a like yeah we like hog
mode or something we would like to find
a way to bring those uh there are a lot
of survival elements in the game but the
trauma system and the weapon degradation
uh we removed uh for this for this
version just because uh it wasn't quite
ready and it was way too hard but we
want to figure out a way to bring it
back if someone said it looks like a
wolverine i'll take it
as a compliment
uh yeah someone was asking uh how the
how does the sci-fi setting give you
like we were talking about the ecology
of the world and everything but you know
like you know
dishonored had that kind of uh
you know wailing uh maybe like almost
steampunk but not exactly just uh
aesthetic with sci-fi what kind of
creative abilities does that give you
um
as far on the artistic side
i think we wanted something that feels
um
like a raw technology a little bit like
terry gilliam uh but more
even though it's super colorful so it's
not as dark as terry gilliam
but we uh yeah we wanted we wanted also
to have our own own spin the same way
you said you know designer that is kind
of like its own vibe and that's what
walt is also trying to achieve here cool
cool so yeah i think we got things
sorted out we'll jump right back into
prey i was just joining this is about
half an hour into the game maybe a
little more
pretty early okay
i think uh should i uh head towards the
office now are we yeah
we can do that oh this is right
i'm just gonna run away
deja shut the door no no no
there you go so i can actually lock them
in now since i hacked the door earlier i
have the code
don't hug the wall here
so these we haven't talked about our
turrets yet these are pretty cool
yeah
those can be moved around can be
repaired um we had um
you know some time with film players uh
when in a test and we have someone
called we we called him the
turret lord
yeah
just carry one around for like hours
yeah more than one yeah it was like the
full turret
the guy didn't use anything else he just
carried turrets around because you can
that's you can play that way if you want
um if you
if you invest in the repair skills right
then you can you can find broken turrets
and fix them when these break you can
put them back in working order but you
can also fortify them
um so you can basically just use the
station defenses to your advantage and
you can turn into a turret
yeah what would be an advantage to
hacking a turret
well uh okay well that's not quite a
spoiler yeah we've talked about that
we've talked about that so as you
take more and more alien powers you
somehow um are detected by the turrets
as an audience so if you did not take
any then the turrets will leave you
alone but when you have when you have
too much too many powers then they start
shooting at you so hacking them turn
them on your side again cool okay
so they like detect a more alien life
form in you or something right yeah okay
so if you're the kind of person who
likes to like read all the notes and
books in the story we have you know
every person on the space station is
named there's no nobody generic
and so you can log into their computers
and see what their emails are so the
this is my office and this was
apparently the morgan's assistant that's
their password to their machine
here's morgan u's office
and so like hey
look at that
my assistant set the uh the key code to
my office to zero four five one ah there
we go there it is
i gotta eat a banana along the way
another uh call back to those looking
glass days
yeah
it's like a little ritual
has been your home for the last three
years
so there's this mysterious uh person
called january who's been helping me
escape and they just told me like i've
been on board the space station for
three years
damn
so this is your office in the game a
place that you will be returning to
on occasion you can since it's an open
space station game you can come back as
as often as you like but occasionally
the story brings you back here
so we have a recycler in here and then
we also have the fabricator like ralph
was talking about it's like a super
advanced like 3d printer of some sort
yeah
yeah
let me grab another recipe so the crafty
crafting system as well is integrated in
the world as an object as opposed to
screen which again was um something we
really wanted
and um
that's great we had you you had the
shotgun yeah i didn't find the shotgun
shells this time some of it's random
but i do have the fabrication plan for
glue ammo
so i'm gonna make some of that
so the ingredients go in here
i'm gonna punch it in
and basically fabricates it
okay
and so now i can't i don't have enough
material so i'd have to go scrounge some
more stuff and
recycle and make more of those little
material blocks okay is there a currency
of some sort in the space station or are
you just relying on crafting materials
to make your own stuff just correcting
material you know those were these
questions we had like should there be
coins and stuff and then we're like you
know what if this is a company like
super high-tech company like some sort
of you know super google or whatever
yeah
uh in space they would probably not have
people pay for things you know it would
be part of
the benefits of being one of these
stations so no there's no money
so now we're gonna watch the secret
video that we left
for ourselves watch me morgan
so occasionally in the game you'll find
these uh videos that are sort of that we
called them uh these look looking glass
videos
it's basically like a 3d video that uh
some of the people on the space station
maybe we start to sound like fun boys
yeah
yeah
first the passcode notes
hello morgan
tough day right
if i'm talking to myself it must be
your memory shot full of holes i know
someone asks how many secrets i know how
secret oriented is the game and uh the
first thing you need and it might be
worth it
so sometimes there's there are secrets
hidden in these videos so um
there's a this room is actually a room
on the space station that you can visit
um
this video was made in the past so in
that room there's a white board that had
a code written on it that's erased but
in the video
uh if you look if you kind of scooch
over and get close you can see that the
code is actually on the screen still
right there or on the whiteboard
explore and go deep
you're not going to like what i have to
say next
then you can choose to be either male or
female more than correct that's right
yeah at the beginning you choose your
gender
so someone asked us about the length of
the game that's that's always a very
hard experience yeah um even more in
this game then and yeah it's harder in
here than this dishonored was uh there
was already a big delta we could say
well you know somewhere between
eight and 16 and it was like sometimes
20 for people who push it
uh here it feels like people who push it
are gonna
they might spend 30 40 hours yeah it's
it's a huge a pretty huge game um
so uh the person who just chimed in
there i mentioned january already so
then there's another character named
alex who is your brother and you meet
him in the first 15 minutes the part
that we we skipped over today
but uh both january and alex are sort of
like pulling at you in different
directions trying to get you to do
different things and it's not quite
clear who the who the antagonist or the
hey i want to report a rumor somebody's
saying january is fontaine
nope gotcha no
it's holding off on that reference
that's right
someone got it for me
yeah i imagine there's going to be you
know like some metroidvania kind of
aspects right going backtracking to
places that you couldn't previously
access
yeah a lot of yes often we hear that
reference
that's not a good idea i'm not gonna do
that
yeah i mean like i was saying the lobby
is a big hub right so uh there are
places i can go to from here like the
shuttle i can go that way and i can go
into the shuttle bay
uh but if i go there now i will likely
get my butt kicked because i don't i
have no business being in there but we
let players do it anyways if they want
to okay and some people will get away
with it
um this big structure here in the middle
is the main lift on the space station uh
and you can see a little map here
where we're here in the lobby then the
space station is like a huge uh
skyscraper floating in space basically
we're here in the lobby you can go down
to the life support area or up to the
arboretum and those are also giant hubs
that lead to other areas but the
elevator's broken initially
but if the players figure out how to fix
it then suddenly they have free reign to
a lot more places
you want to talk about the exterior also
we didn't even mention that yeah
yeah so you can actually navigate uh we
talked about this at the very beginning
i think the the
it's some sort of a
we call it open space station because
really you can go anywhere in this in
the station you can come back everything
is persistent everything remembers you
uh but you can also fly outside of it
and explore the entire area around the
space station which is huge uh so it's a
little bit like being in a forest of an
open world and there are little points
of interest outside you can some of them
you can see them from inside and it like
here we're seeing that something very
exploded so there's probably something
to go see there and later on when you
can actually access outside then you
remember it and you can try see it
because it's all contiguous it all makes
sense it's all it's one space
right now our the story would like us to
go to that that point of view the
hardware labs yeah hardware labs but
right now i do want to show like some of
the marketing area or something yeah so
the marketing area is uh
blocked off by a bunch of like
barricades i can't get in there so i'm
gonna go find a recycle i'm gonna break
into the security booth and see if i can
find some more
uh weapons and stuff like that
so like you said if you had if you
picked up different items or you went
down a different skill tree you might
have been doing all of this in a
different order
exactly yeah
so i don't have the key to that but look
oh crawl space we learned about those
earlier
hopefully there's not a mimic in here
so we're in the security chiefs office
now
so this is where you find the shotgun uh
normally okay actually
i just triggered combat focus on
accident sorry i was getting too relaxed
and like damn with that shotgun
but now i have some bullets yay
some shells rather
uh so some some i think somebody was
asking about this like are they always
can you find the code here's a good
example of one where like if i had
hacking level three i could hack it but
i don't but this is one where the the
lock isn't actually broken so i can find
the code
so like knowing who this character is
might help me figure out what the code
is and like so on her desk there's this
little book with a reference
that's probably the secret
all right
now i got now i have somebody was asking
about recipes earlier i just picked up
the fabrication license for shotgun
shell so now i can make as many shotgun
shells as i want
this is what i'm here for is the
recycler charge so the recycler charge
is the portable version of the recycler
it's a one-time use
uh and people use it on board of the
station to
clean up the space you know there's an
area that's clouded you use this
of course it's dangerous so if you are
in it's in its radius it might it might
recycle you as well
and you can use it as a weapon because
it will also recycle aliens
so
uh it's actually i really like that
gadget i like the
the feel of it and it's it's funny so
and then you'll see the little recycler
element coming out of it after it's done
recycling things is that one locked too
yeah that one's locked
so this one has a barricade so we'll use
the uh
the recycler charge here
oh yeah i see why you definitely
wouldn't want to be near that yeah oh
then it becomes materials you can use
something yeah okay you can use yeah so
it's all again you know part of one big
world where everything somehow this is
oh this is human resources it's not
marketing
oh well
there's a marketing next door no it's
upstairs yeah marketing is the first
person ever that wants to go to human
resources exactly
so ryan krebs i believe it was in the
youtube chat was just uh he was asking
can you get through the game without
using alien powers maybe just sticking
to gadgets absolutely yeah it's uh
in fact you won't be able to have all
abilities so if you really want to go
deep on the human tree then you pretty
much can't say alien powers or very
little amount okay
a tank up on caffeine
you notice like the stamina bar you have
does that can you increase the max
stamina at all or is that just a static
thing
yeah it's more like um you can you can
uh increase the the speed rate
of recharge and you can play with it
basically if you we can actually show
the
second if you show the tree related to
the stamina bar oh yeah yeah
that's in security
then
it's probably down there yeah
there we go so there's a whole tree
that's related to physical stuff so it
starts with conditioning let's go ahead
and take that
um which gives you some hit points and
some speed um and then you have
toughness
stamina and mobility but then if you
look down to the wrench part um
oh it's
on the it's actually the engineer thing
all right um
you can also wrench damage yeah you can
also combine the your stamina with the
the idea that now your
it actually uses less damage every time
you use your wrench
so
and does and critical hits things yeah
so you can actually really optimize you
know combine all these things together
to be the supreme
ranch basher guy
okay
i took leverage
it's the same way
yeah someone was asking since turrets
might eventually recognize you as aliens
will other aliens ever recognize you as
alien
uh
no they they know
they know you're something different
yeah they're a little smarter than the
turrets there's there's a creature that
we've talked about before and we've
shown in some of the trailers called the
nightmare okay which is designed
specifically the other aliens are just
part of the ecology they're evolving
they're they're they're indiscriminately
killing everyone but the nightmare is
made specifically to kill you okay like
it hunts you down and it's not scripted
it's totally systemic okay like the more
in neuromods you use the more like heat
you generate which attracts the
nightmare and so it can show up in
almost any level in the game gotcha one
anecdote i think it's about bioshock 2.
the big sisters was originally going to
be one big sister that was hunting you
kind of procedurally throughout the game
yeah i always kind of thought that would
be cool or like resident evil 3 nemesis
yeah that's that yeah that's very
similar cool
i got uh i grabbed leverage one but i
don't think
i think the barricades there are bigger
i think they're leveraging two items
yeah i was playing
i was
in the middle of a play through the
other day and i was in my office but it
was way later in the game
i was in morgan's office
and i had some there are some allies
that you can meet later and if you help
them out they show up in your office and
they become people who give you other
side quests and things like that oh cool
um and i had them all in my office with
me
and i forgot about the nightmare
and i was just like oh i got like 20
neuromods i'm gonna like totally
i was just back at my home base so i'm
just gonna like fabricate some stuff and
i'm gonna install a neuramod and get
some more alien abilities i installed
like three new alien abilities and i was
like cool let's do the next mission and
all of a sudden i heard this like huge
roar
of screen shake and the nightmare
actually came into my office it's like
how tall is like 12 meters tall but it
can squeeze through doorways and it
killed the two people in my office it
killed january and then it killed me
so there's no safe place from it not
really damn
i could just permanently screw up your
npc's friends yeah
someone asked if there's a possibility
to unlock every ability so we have to
restart the new story you will have to
restart a new story
okay
and of course since it's an immersive
sim you can drink from the water bounds
and collect toilets
as you do you're gonna you can't drink
from the toilet i guess you could
pretend like
that's what you're doing
okay
hey where's the what is the glue gun
for within the world what was it was
like an engineering tool before it was
uh something that they used to uh
in case aliens would escape containment
they use that to
to control them okay
did you say that was jason chang
did it
oh so that was his computer you read
earlier
yeah oh yeah that's my assistant
jason
crap man
what happened it's too bad
yeah
yeah
did you guys notice his password was omg
hot boss
yeah oh do you have a crush on you yeah
yeah jason has a crush on you gotcha
that's too bad what happened to jason
oops i was trying to set up a turret
i think i think i murdered everything in
the lobby already
how are we doing on time
got about five minutes left five minutes
what do you want to show in the last
five minutes
uh uh what is the the room with the
the projector that's the marketing thing
oh that's what i was going to do but
yeah there's a room in here full of
mimics but i'm going to use the turret
to kill them instead of
let's go in the turret lord route that's
right
let's see you can see him running around
there
i love that little flicker out of the
corner you see yep
oh the trick is
[Music]
see but they're hiding now they know
what i'm trying to do
oh ah they knocked my turret down
no
best laid place
all right that did not work out
all right we're just gonna go back to
combat focus
it's brute force that's right
so we're playing an easy by the way yeah
while they're distracted
come on
there we go that's what i'm talking
about
right there
oh we also didn't
when we were showing the different
accesses two other places we did not
show the psychotronics access as well
oh yeah that's right
you can go there
so yeah the door is locked and that's a
good example actually of something where
you know you could find the key card but
you can also just look around and
actually if you break the glass there
[Music]
computer so later in the game though
it's you know this is early so that's a
little easier later in the game like the
button will be all the way across the
room and so then you have to
do stuff like well there's an alien
power that allows you to manipulate
machines from a distance okay cool
um
they're different oh i can't get in here
yet keep that
yeah
i think that's about all the territory
we have to cover for uh
yeah
so that's a good example of if you play
if you just follow the path and uh you
probably would be
it would probably take like 20 minutes
to
be to the same point right yeah but
really here we spent about an hour plus
the time that we would have spent uh at
the you know the 15 minutes for the
opening yeah and i didn't in this one
room at this one level i didn't even hit
all the spots because i don't have
yeah i don't have the ability to open
everything so
cool so that's why i hear that you know
the time could be the play time could be
either 20 minutes or an hour and a half
almost yes you know see the delta the
cherry and two kind of players oh one
last little detail this place where i
fought the phantom i forgot to mention
earlier is a cool it's like a little
museum uh exhibit for those of you guys
who are interested in like the back
story and the details of the world
there's like you can sort of learn about
like the history of the space station
and the fact that our game is like it's
built on this alternate version of
history where kennedy survived
and as a result you know technology is
different in the world and that's why in
2035 we have this giant skyscraper
floating around the moon
cool
awesome
that's it yeah i guess we can call it
there
i'd love to see more but
this will be out on uh
may 5th for ps4 xbox one pc uh refcol
antonio thanks so much for joining me
thank you ricardo bear yeah thanks for
fun view i didn't die this time yeah i
hope the gamers enjoyed it yeah
everybody in the youtube twitch game
spot thanks so much for joining us uh
we're gonna have a lot of coverage
coming out gdc this week i'm sure we'll
have more prey coverage coming up to uh
its release on may 5th uh we do have a
couple live streams tomorrow we're
playing zelda 8 to 11 a.m pacific time
uh you know our nintendo switch review
is up we'll have our zelda review up
early tomorrow morning so uh for that
and for of course more prey coverage
stay tuned to gamespot thanks for
joining us bye
[Music]
c
you